foreign
September 13 2022 22 year old Masa amini
is visiting at rand's Capital to run
with her family her and her brother are
on the way to a local Metro station when
something goes terribly wrong Masa is
stopped by the police for questioning
but it's not just any old police force
you find in every city around the world
it's Iran's notorious morality police a
special police unit that's what
enforcing Islamic dress codes throughout
the country and there's really only one
thing they care about Iranian women
their clothes and more specifically
their headscarves or hijabs
unfortunately Masa amini was wearing her
her job that day a little bit too loose
for the morality police's taste God
forbid anyone does that so they
immediately confronted her and what
happens to women when they don't wear
their hijabs correctly they get arrested
on the spots no warnings no fines women
simply get arrested for inappropriate
appearance yes that is an actual crime
in Iran they get thrown into the
morality police car and then they get
shipped off to a re-education center it
kind of detention center where you have
to go through and lesson on modesty on
whether hijab is mandatory in Iran and
why not wearing it correctly is a crime
once they sign a pledge and Sport to
never disobey iren's dress code again
they are set free
but in the case of Masa amini she wasn't
so lucky three days after her detention
she ended up dead 22 year old Masa amini
this accusation that she was beaten she
was tortured and killed in the custody
of Iran's morality police to the public
the morality police said that she
suffled several heart attacks during her
re-education and was rushed to the
hospital because 22 year old healthy
women definitely have heart attacks all
the time what a joke conveniently no one
had been allowed to see her alive no one
was allowed to investigate her death and
no one was allowed near her body after
she died no autopsy in the past the
government probably would have been able
to get away with this lie but not this
time because today the Iranian people
have the internet so they quickly found
out what really happened to her there's
footage of her being thrown into a bus
hitting her head on impact Witnesses
started coming forward saying that the
police beat Masa over and over again
that she was tortured fell into a coma
and died from her injuries all because
of a piece of clothing covering her hair
when the troop behind masa's death hit
the streets all hell broke loose
thousands of women in Iran stormed the
streets protesting against their
oppressive regime they started ripping
off and burning their hijabs and some
were even cutting off their hair in
public it's the biggest Revolt Iran has
seen in years and in response the
Iranian government hit back with full
force initiating a vicious Crackdown
against everyone who opposes them they
blacked out the internet there were Mass
arrests of protesters and they're
threatening anyone who dares to fight
their religious Authority
before a Crackdown like this would have
been enough but this time something is
different this time the threats and
arrests aren't scaring the masses into
submission this time people are only
getting angrier louder and stronger and
is pushing Iran to the very edge
stay dangerous click the Subscribe
button and this is the Iran crisis
[Music]
and if you want some free stuff you can
get up to 12 free stocks value up to
thirty thousand six hundred dollars when
you sign up for Weeble and deposit any
amount with the link below there's no
catch all you have to do is open an
account deposit as little as one dollar
and that is it you'll get up to 12 free
stocks value up to 30 600 deposited
straight into your accounts and yes once
the stocks have settled in your accounts
you can sell them use that money to buy
other stocks or even withdraw the money
so you might as well pause the video and
click the link below to claim your free
stocks now because this promotion is
definitely not gonna last forever
signing up is super fast and easy all
you have to do is fill out some basic
information deposit some money and
you're done the first two shares you get
when you open your account will be
valued up to three hundred dollars each
and the next four to ten shares you get
after you deposit some money in your
account would be valued up to three
thousand dollars each we are going into
a recession right now so you're gonna
wanna make sure you have everything set
up and ready to go so that you can buy
if and when everything crashes and
Weeble is the app to do it it's a really
great Commission free stock trading app
that was ranked the best investment app
in 2021 by benzinga and it has a 4.5
star rating From Nerd wallet so what are
you waiting for get your 12 free stocks
battery up to 30 600 right now by
pausing the video and clicking the link
below thanks to Weeble for sponsoring
this video
before the Iranian Revolution in 1979
Iran was completely different to what it
is today it was actually a tourist
capital of the Middle East Americans and
Europeans would flock there to vacation
and women were allowed to dress however
they wanted it was actually a pretty
liberal peaceful country compared to
today
after the 1979 Revolution however things
took a complete 180. strict Islamic
rulers took over the country and the
country descended Into Darkness Iran was
now an Islamic Republic governed by
Islamic law American Music films and
fashion are outlawed any liberals left
were thrown into prison or killed and
women had to now wear hijabs covering
their entire head and neck not a single
hair must be seen in public because they
consider a woman exposing her hair in
public as literally the same equivalent
as her being naked we definitely don't
want these temptresses tempting men now
would we so there are no exceptions it
doesn't matter if you're a local a
foreigner a Muslim or a Christian you
either follow the Iranian dress code or
you face ugly consequences and the new
government quickly put together a
morality police force to make sure women
fell into line called the Islamic
revolution committees
but she still has this SCAR Where
morality police cut her hand demanding
she cover her hair but she removed her
hijab in protest
[Music]
she was also arrested by morality police
her crime showing her bare wrist she was
thrown into a police car while her
family tried to save her
if you're a woman and you're caught
violating the Islamic dress code in Iran
you face one of two outcomes if you're
lucky getting arrested for inappropriate
appearance earned you a day at a
re-education center where you're
verbally abused into submission and
forced to sign a pledge never to let
your hair show in public again if you're
not so lucky you end up at that same
re-education Center but instead of
yelling you're beaten to a pulp so they
can really get the message across
and if you're really unlucky that one
day re-education camp can turn into two
months in prison to give you enough time
to reflect on the horrendous crime
you've committed that is the reality of
life for Iranian women for the past 40
years and since then pretty much every
woman in Iran especially in the capital
Tehran has some kind of horror story to
tell when it comes to the morality
police
Iranian women have been humiliated and
abused for decades over the way they
dress and every year they've had to take
it hoping they'll make it another day
without being arrested for wearing jeans
or a T-shirt and in 2021 it only got
worse
foreign
Ibrahim raisi became Iran's new
president thanks to what many believed
to be a rigged election and like any
good dictator he had some unique ideas
on how to better control the Iranian
people two words total surveillance
but not just any surveillance like
catching criminals and potential
terrorists
this time it was all about monitoring
women who didn't dress appropriately
women who showed too much skin or a
little bit of their hair introduction of
surveillance cameras to Monitor and find
unveiled women or referred them for
counseling but it went further than that
on top of women any Iranian whether male
or female who posted content against the
hijab rules online could also face
prison time in mandatory prison sentence
for any Iranian who questioned or posted
content against the hijab rules online
thanks to this new Total surveillance
program women wouldn't just be punished
for publicly defying the Islamic dress
code they could be thrown in jail for
even complaining about it in private
understandably Iranian women were
Furious all the corruption and violence
by their oppressive government on top of
the insane hijab laws has led to a lot
of tension in Iran over the last few
years but adding Mass surveillance and
mandatory prison in time on top of that
it was the final straw so instead of
giving in to this totalitarian move or
hiding out of fear women began pushing
back the protests had started long
before Masa amini was ever arrested
their anger and resentment had been
boiling underneath the surface for so
long just waiting to be erupted and the
news about Masa amini's death was the
final straw
thank you
after the protests broke out the first
reaction of any oppressive regime is
always sending in the police force so
that's what they did since then the
results have been brutal over 100
protesters have already been killed so
far on top of that the Iranian
government shut down the internet
WhatsApp Instagram Facebook Twitter
telegram Tick Tock the people couldn't
use any of these apps to organize or
communicate luckily Elon Musk came to
the rescue and activated starlink over
Iran and yet somehow despite the heavy
Crackdown and even military soldiers
shooting into the crowds the protests
continued
it seems like President rice C
completely underestimated his people's
willpower especially the strength of
Iran's women the poor the middle class
artists entrepreneurs people from all
walks of life are on the streets
fighting for their freedom because it's
not simply about the hijab it's much
deeper than that all the corruption the
oppression all the police brutality that
the people have had to suffer through
for decades it's all coming to the
surface
and now they are demanding the
dictator's head
[Applause]
many women also chanted
and it's not just in bigger cities like
Terra everywhere even in smaller cities
there on the streets protesting for
their freedom even as we're writing this
video more protests erupted after the
body of a 16 year old protester was
found 10 days after she disappeared
during protests in Tehran Revolution is
in the air but unlike America where
people can own guns it's definitely not
like that in Iran so all we can say is
massive respect to the Iranian people
and Godspeed
remember how we mentioned that before
the Iranian Revolution in 1979 Iran was
actually a pretty peaceful and liberal
place that attracted westerners women
could dress how they pleased and how
After the Revolution Iran descended into
complete darkness ruled under Islamic
law well guess who instigated that
Revolution oh would you look at that it
was the U.S
see back then the Middle East was rather
peaceful it still had its problems but
it definitely wasn't as chaotic in
war-torn as it is today that was until
the U.S got involved in 1953 the CIA got
the green light for Operation Ajax their
mission get the Iranian prime minister
mosadig out of power dead or alive so
they launched a coup but not just any
coup this was the very first time in
history the CIA decided to overthrow a
democratically elected government
and it worked the Iran coup became one
of the most successful covert operations
in CIA history what they didn't account
for was all the consequences this coup
would lead to in fact almost every major
Middle Eastern Terror event all the Wars
all the suffering sense that can be
traced back to this one CIA operation
and we'll give you a hint it was all
about oil
the problem is covering the entire Iran
coup of 1953 and the terror that
followed would definitely get
demonetized on YouTube that's why we've
released a private documentary on the
Iran coup of 1953 only available to
members of this channel that you can
watch right now by clicking the join
button below
channel members have been loving it and
it will give you a better understanding
of why Iran is in chaos today once
you're a member of our Channel you will
also have access to all the other
private documentaries like our latest
one on the connection between Victoria's
Secret and everyone's favorite island
owner every chapstick
people bury themselves in debt for
university only to leave not knowing how
the world really works this on the other
hand does give you a glimpse into how
the world works for only five dollars a
month
and you can guarantee that these
documentaries are way more entertaining
compared to lectures and there's a
refund policy too unlike most YouTube
memberships so if you join and you don't
think it's worth it email us within your
first month of joining for the first
time and we will personally refund you
for your first month after your first
month there is no refund so scroll down
and hit that join button now
it feels like this that remind me that
we have it pretty good in America for
all its flaws most of the problems we
have here are very much first world
problems but yeah let me know what you
guys think in the comments below if
you're new here this is one of the
biggest channels on YouTube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime so you can learn how the world
really works instead of becoming a
victim to it so if you like the
philosophy if you want to be more
dangerous click that subscribe button
below it's free you can unsubscribe
whenever you want and you can leave me
your best hate comments whenever you
want so you have nothing to lose you can
follow me on Instagram jakestram but
that is going to wrap it up thanks for
being part of the watch the end Club
stay dangerous out there and I will see
you guys in the next one
foreign
[Music]